this is the double nest hammock by
eagles nest outfitters it's a hundred
percent nylon measures about six feet in
width by nine feet in length so you can
fit two people in it comfortably it
holds up to 400 pounds and packs down to
the size of a softball and weighs about
22 ounces so if you want to go
backpacking you can stick in your pack
or if you just want to hang out in the
park and drag along with you the double
nest cost 60 495 it's a lot easier to
set up with the optional $20 straps
basically nylon webbing that you can
wrap around a tree and then click to and
it's a lot more comfortable than
sleeping on the ground it's really
strong and had no problems with it
except for having to find the right
distance between two trees to set it up
to the right height a few things go with
a hammock like a nice cold beer
the problem is if you've got an open
beer in your lap when you're in a
hammock it's not gonna be long before it
ends up all over the place which is why
Stanley's 1913 a carbonated drink holder
comes in so handy it comes with domed
ends so it can handle the pressure of
holding your carbonated drink and a wide
mouth opening for easy port and it makes
for a lot more mess free drinking so
this guy runs for 28 bucks and it's
basically the classy man's brown bag